le mouvement de la terre si on dit qu'il
y à des mouvements c'est qu'il y a moins
deux mouvements en effet la terre à deux
mouvements
le premier mouvement c'est un mouvement
de rotation sur elle-même
c'est ce qu'on appelle la rotation de la
terre en 24 heures la terre revient à
son point de départ
il ya un deuxième mouvement qui est la
révolution la révolution de la terre
c'est le mouvement une map que fait la
terre pendant un an
en fait c'est un parcours autour du
soleil pendant un an elle va tourner
autour du soleil vous voyez elle
continue bien sûr avoir sa rotation tous
les jours elle tourne sur elle même mais
en plus elle tourne autour du soleil
c'est un mouvement évidemment cycliques
puisqu'elle revient toujours finalement
0 c'est ce qu'on appelle une année donc
on a un nom la terre fait le tour du
soleil tout en continuant à tourner sur
elle-même rotation de la terre et
révolution de la nous allons ici étudié
quatre positions qui sont assez
remarquable parce qu'elles offrent des
coques des caractéristiques assez
particulière il ya deux positions
on va appeler les équinoxes et les deux
autres qu'on va appeler les solstices
vous voyez ici
voilà la terre à l'équinoxe de mars
c'est souvent aux alentours du 21 mars
ça peut être un peu plus tard 22 ou 23
mai je vais vous montrer le profil de la
terre dont vous voyez on c'est comme si
on plaçait une caméra ici sur le côté et
qu'un observateur comme ça regarde ce
qui se passe mais voilà ce qui se passe
vous voyez que la terre continue à
tourner sur elle-même mais aux alentours
du 21 mars l'ensemble des deux
hémisphères sont éclairés de la même
manière en fait
voyez il n'y a pas une partie qui est
plus éclairés que l'autre dont sur
toutes les localisations qu'on peut
avoir
il ya 12 heures de jour et 12 heures de
nuit ça c'est la particularité d
équinoxe à l'équinoxe de printemps en
mars ou l'équinoxe d'automne
en septembre le jour
dure plus ou moins 12 heures ou qu'on
soit sur le bloc très intéressant alors
un petit peu avancé on va aller vers le
solstice alors évidemment le solstice
d'été
voyez que tout doucement l'inclinaison
de la terre va influencer cette fois-ci
l'exposition du soleil puisque
contrairement à la situation précédente
ici il ya eu un hémisphère qui va être
plus exposé claude voyez que
l'hémisphère nord est beaucoup plus
exposés
d'ailleurs on va remarquer qu ici au
delà du cercle polaire arctique
oui mais on n'est jamais dans le noir
donc en fait le jour dure 24 heures par
contre au cercle polaire antarctique
celle inverse
voyez que la zone ne va jamais dans la
zone lumineuse et donc au solstice
d'hiver l'ensemble du cercle polaire
antarctique connaît la nuit il n'y a pas
de jour pendant 24 heures c'est l'ami
évidemment dans toutes les régions qui
sont situées à l'hémisphère nord le jour
va durer beaucoup plus longtemps il va
devrait durer plus de 12 heures
c'est ce qu'on connaît en été en était
le soleil va se lever peut-être vers 6
heures et va se coucher vers 22 heures
on a là une luminosité qui est maximale
c'est le jour le solstice d'été c'est le
jour où la durée du jour et le la pub
ok alors ce qui est remarquable aussi
c'est que voyez ici on a représenté le
tropique du cancer avait aux tropiques
du cancer le jour du solstice d'été au
mois de juin nous allons tous du 21 juin
les rayons solaires arrive vraiment à la
perpendiculaire sont vraiment à 90
degrés par rapport à la surface du sol
donc un observateur qui serait là à ce
moment là à midi le soleil va être
vraiment tout au dessus de sa tête
vraiment au zénith ce qui n'arrive
jamais chez nous alors on va continuer
le petit parcours
voilà on est au mois de juillet les
jours commencent à raccourcir et puis on
va arriver évidemment septembre les
kings et septembre et là qu'est ce qui
se passe
la durée du jour on va être de 12 heures
partout la surface du globe
ici ça va être à l'équateur
voyez
que le soleil sera vraiment à la
verticale sera au zénith ce jour là aux
deux equinox le soleil est au zénith à
l'équateur je continue nous allons aller
vers le solstice d'hiver et voyez qu'on
a une position qui est totalement
inversée par rapport au solstice d'été
puisque la le cercle polaire arctique ne
connaît pas le jour c'est la nuit
permanente pendant 24 heures
le cercle polaire antarctique lui au
contraire c'est un jour c'est une
journée qui dure 24 heures à effet est
clair pendant 24 heures et l'hémisphère
sud est beaucoup plus éclairés chez nous
dans l'hémisphère nord
la durée du jour beaucoup plus courte
elle va être inférieure à 12 heures vous
voyez aussi que la les rayons solaires
cette fois ci ne seront plus
perpendiculaire à la surface aux
tropiques du cancer mais ici ça sera
autre pic du capricorne et je termine
mon parcours en revenant à la position
de départ qu'il était l'équinoxe de
printemps au mois d'avril